you know like it or not they're just
some annoying things in the world okay
so me and some friends were hanging out
at this billiard bowling alley it was a
nice place and at a point I noticed this
guy he's just staring at me I thought he
worked there either that or he just
thought I had a great ass we were
getting ready to leave and then he comes
up to me and he starts sales pitching me
he's all like hey I just started a
business I think you'd do well in I'm
looking for leaders you dressed nice and
well blah blah blah a bunch of other
crap you don't care about and I pretty
much thought what anyone would think
crap one of these so after he graciously
offered to suck up 30 minutes of my time
explaining okay so that's me and that's
you I told him no thanks he walked this
way I walked that way and that was that
and I felt okay about it because then
this economy pyramid schemes are the
only jobs being handed out in abundance
so when someone tells you excuse me hi
I'd like to talk to you about a great
opportunity what they really mean is
excuse me hi can i waste your time I
don't know about you but it makes me
kind of uncomfortable I just want to be
like okay you stay back I guess airborne
aids you don't want this [ __ ] you ha and
I mean to be fair the guy could have
been legit he could have been like thank
you for talking with me I'm gonna level
with you I'm dying my empire is now
yours I mean I suppose there is a
possibility that he could have made me
mayor of candy land or the bunny ranch
yeah now we're talking about candy land
I'm a bunny ranch bunny ranch would be
awesome but I guess I'll never know
it was totally gonna be a pyramid scheme
damn you pyramid people for killing the
dream and I would like to remind
everyone the term pyramid people is not
a derogatory term aimed at Egyptians
minds or these guys yes to all people
who approach people hammered on Jack and
Coke and billiards and bowling alleys
trying to sell them on pyramid schemes I
think I speak for the entire human race
when I say you're self-serving antics to
make money off of our gullibility is
more annoying than getting friend
request from nameless garage bands on
Facebook I only say this because I think
these people should know how annoying
they actually are pyramid scheme sales
pictures are like the herpes of the
shitty job market they pop up when and
where they want may cause nothing but
severe irritation Baniya range would be
awesome so I'm wondering have you guys
ever tried a pyramid scheme and if so
has it ever worked out for you or do you
guys find it about as annoying as I do
I'm really wondering cuz I personally
have never known a human being who has
tried a pyramid scheme and had it worked
out like ever and if neither will feel
free to use my comment section to [ __ ]
about your job
or praise it in either case they'll
never know anonymity is the key to
YouTube ten less you're a total dumbass
who uses his name as
they knew his YouTube channel crap